they never gave up some persistent spca
staff worked with this little tabby
to help her overcome a rare disorder to
regain the use
of her legs imagine here's elizabeth
king there we go
elizabeth king reports baby girl this is
timber a two-year-old
orange tabby who was brought into the
placer spca
about six months ago and they soon
noticed timber was in trouble
every time she took a step her kneecaps
would pop out
both of them and while that can happen
with cats
it's a bit unusual without expensive
orthopedic surgery to correct the
condition
timber was in danger of toppling over if
you had bad knees
you would want to receive the treatment
that you needed as opposed to us saying
well we can't help you
we're just going to give up on you or
you can't live but then a family
foundation actually stepped up
and provided most of the funding for her
surgery which was fabulous
but her road to recovery involves
something most cats
try to avoid swimming in water we can
have the water go up to whatever level
is appropriate fortunately the facility
had just purchased this 40
thousand dollar underwater treadmill
it's originally designed for dogs but
timber took to it with open paws it was
exactly what she needed
she had to be limited on putting weight
on her knees
but she needed exercise and they say the
hydrotherapy
has worked perfectly after all of this
rehabilitation
timber is going up for adoption a
special needs cat
now looking for that special place to
live out her life i think what she
really needs
is just that loving caring perfect home
oh and she'll get it for sure my
goodness she's a love